PROFESSOR JOEL
SCHINDALL: This course
represents one of
four courses that
are given in the Gordon
Leadership Program.
We have a course on engineering
innovation and design,
a course on engineering
leadership, a course on people
and organizations, which talks
about how to work effectively
within a company, and of
course on project engineering,
which teaches them how to use
the same tools and skills they
learned when they assemble
electronic systems to assemble
the management system
that it takes in order
to run a complicated program.
When we got funding for
the Gordon MIT Engineering
Leadership Program,
we got together
with a number of
industry leaders,
actually quite a large
number of industry leaders,
to look at what was
engineering leadership
and what were they looking for
in the successful engineers
within their companies.
About 3/4 of the topics
had to do with leadership--
decision-making, advocacy,
cross-cultural communication--
but about a quarter
of the topics
that they really
were looking for had
to do with good
engineering designers.
And they were talking
not just about being
skilled in the
craft, but actually
looking at the world in a
way where they realized what
was wanted and
needed, what was it
the people who are using
this product might require,
and they actually came up with
elegant, innovative designs.
They observed that
a small portion
of the engineers that they hired
seemed to have that ability,
and a much larger
portion of them
would do competent
design work, but just
didn't pick up on the kinds
of breakthrough designs
that the smaller group could do.
Rather than teach the
students the design skills
of a particular
engineering discipline,
we work to teach the students
to think like designers--
to be able to get
outside the problem
itself and look at what is
the purpose of this project
or product or process?
What function does it serve?
What is the need that is
required out in the world?
And how can I innovatively
and creatively use the tools
that I have learned
in order to design,
invent, produce, and
implement something
that will satisfy this need?
So we put together
a course which
is a combination of
10 design principles,
Socratic inquiry, and the
students themselves being
engaged in design
projects, and supported
by some student
teaching assistants,
which engages and
provokes the students
to develop these
kinds of abilities
and causes them to
leave the course not so
much with a specific
body of knowledge--
we don't actually care
whether they continue
doing that specific
design project--
but what we want them to do--
and they do, in fact, they
can't avoid it-- is to apply
this way of thinking to the way
that they go about
solving future problems.
I actually had a
career in industry
after graduating
from MIT, 35 years
in aerospace and
telecommunications,
but I couldn't resist
the opportunity
to come back and
give back by helping
MIT's young students develop the
kind of attitude and behavior
that is necessary to be
effective as an engineer today.
PROFESSOR BLADE KOTELLY: We're
successful if a student exits
the course having
completely changed
the way they think
about the world.
And I know that sounds
like a strange thing.
And what we mean, is
that hopefully they
see everything differently.
When they're walking
down the street
and they pass a door
handle, they think,
why is the door handle
designed that way?
Does it communicate effectively
to me to know how to use it?
What about other people?
Would they understand
how to use it?
What's the material made
of, which material's
involved in that door handle?
How has it been used?
Is it smudged?
Is it clear?
Is it clear against
the background?
Hopefully, they see
everything differently
in the vast interconnectedness
of everything in the world.
And the fact that
everything we do
is ultimately in
service to people.
So if you're making a
part for space station,
it might have to be replaced
by someone or diagnosed,
so that is in service to people.
People to operate
a bigger system
that can tell us more
about how we live.
So if they walk out of the
class being able to do that,
we're successful.
PROFESSOR JOEL
SCHINDALL: One way
in which I like to
challenge the students
at the end of the course
is to point out to them
that the course
is not ending now.
It's beginning now.
We actually gave them
the instruction set
and the way of thinking.
Their job now is to
go out into the world
and to use that
thinking in order
to be more effective designers.
And here's a gotcha.
Once your eyes are open to that,
as has happened in this class,
you can't stop doing it.
So a year from now, or two
years from now, or five years
from now, I expect
to hear back from you
that you faced or
came up with some kind
of a creative solution to
a longstanding problem.
And I'm going to take great
satisfaction in the fact
that you came up
with that solution,
but some of the tools and the
ways of looking at the world
that we discussed
in this class will
have been the enabling or
the facilitating factor
in your effectiveness
of doing that.